hi i'm eric gloss and i'm phillip molina
and avengers in-game was the best of
emotional roller coasters roller
coasters that redefine quantum physics
and kill your best friends can require
two people to break it down because
those roller coasters are not safe there
is so much movie to break down three
hours of satisfying nods to marvel past
an even
subtler layer of meaning hidden in the
visual and background details
and little sneaky winks from the
filmmakers to reward obsessives like us
for re-watching the movie over and over
and over and over again which we already
have done and we haven't slept we are
going to cover it all
scene by scene and spoiler warning in
case you know we've
already predicted anything too right and
your life is already ruined sorry
if you somehow haven't seen the movie
yet what's it like to have your mind
still intact must feel nice avengers end
game
opens on the farm home of clint barton
hawkeye m.i.a and infinity war and now
facing his turn at heartbreak his
opening line is an archery lesson to his
daughter lila played by ava russo
real-life daughter of co-director joe
russo he says you see where you're going
now let's worry about how you get there
hearing this over the opening
image of an arrow tip reflects in game's
deeper meaning as a story about
destinations and trajectories
in this coming time heist a term coined
from a guy that clint last saw clinging
to one of these aero tips
identifying the destinations will be a
lot easier of a challenge
than the meticulously precise trajectory
that they must bullseye to succeed at it
so
already here we're noticing some nods to
past mcu films hawkeye wears an ankle
monitor which he
and scott lang both had to wear after
their involvement in civil war
because they're the two family men and
they couldn't get on team cap they
couldn't go on the run and abandon their
families also this exact target that
they're practicing on
appeared already in clint's barn in age
of ultron and clint calls his daughter
hawkeye which is
actually kind of crazy that name almost
never gets said out loud in the mcu it's
like he's ashamed of it but it does
indicate that maybe lila barton might be
being set up as a future kate bishop
legacy figure ah but
not so fast because you can't really
fire an arrow in your pile of dust
all of clint's family lila his wife
laura his sons cooper and nate
they all dust away and if you're
listening closely the sound mixers work
in some ominous
rumble of thunder that accompanied the
snapdramath and infinity war in wakanda
oh god oh yes i'm calling this aftermath
i will never call it the decimation
moving on to the marvel studios title
which
erased all the dusted characters who
used to be there like black panther and
star-lord and groot and left only these
six original avengers they also erased
ant-man which is kind of rude because
dude wasn't dead but
he was just in the quantum realm to the
survivors i guess that is as good as
being dusted but not to erect and the
music here
is dear mr fantasy by traffic and that's
a song that must have been on like the
zune that yondu left for
peter quill back in guardians vol 2. the
lyrics though
perfectly reflect what we're asking tony
stark to do in this movie dear mr
fantasy play us
a tune do anything take us out of this
gloom make it snappy
please don't be sad if it was a straight
mind you had we wouldn't have known you
all these years
tony is our mr fantasy and rescuing the
universe from the
post thanos gloom with a snappy move of
his own
all from the mad scientist who maybe if
he had had a straight mind all those
years ago we wouldn't have known you all
these years these
11 years that we got with him so stark
and nebula are on board the benetar
they're drifting out in space away from
titan they're flicking these folded
footballs
not only does this foreshadow start
flicking ant-man later in the film
football will essentially be the name of
the game in the movie's third act with
stark's gauntlet
as the football being passed from
avenger to avenger on this huge rush to
the goal line though with all this
unnecessary roughness it's more like
rugby nebula ends up winning this game
a first for her considering she always
loses against gamora throughout their
youth when they would have to spar for
thanos leading to her becoming a walking
pile of scraps
in the infinity gauntlet comics nebula
has a massive victory
in this comeback against thanos and this
in-game film shows nebula's first
on-screen victory
then tony records a goodbye message to
pepper and his helmet saying they've
been stranded for
22 days one day for every mcu movie
which would have been a nice way for him
to pass that time but he probably didn't
have access to netflix stark also made a
similar helmet recording for pepper and
iron man 3
and here he begins it by saying not to
post it on social media which is both a
meta comment to fans to not spoil
endgame on social media but it's
also a callback to the opening of the
first iron man i don't want to see this
on your myspace [ __ ] god that is such
an old movie now
tony ends the message by signing off
saying it's you
it's always been you which is what he
told pepper when he made her ceo of
stark industries in iron man 2.
it's you it's always been you and as he
says this
tony slides his thumb along the helmet's
eyepiece
as if wiping away a tear the helmet is
scarred and damaged on its right side
foreshadowing stark's appearance at the
moment of his death mortally wounded
from his gauntlet snap on his right side
captain marvel then rescues tony and
nebula and from watching this movie
alone
it's not totally clear how carol danvers
knew
where to find him and if she just
stumbled upon him or something the
post-credits scene of captain marvel did
show her arriving at avengers
headquarters on earth and that scene
wasn't in this movie so
maybe just carol learned from rocket
where the benatar's homing signal was
and tracked it that way
sure also that would mean that thor was
not interested in saving them who knows
when she then tows them back home though
tony is now struggling to stand
part of that is because of earth's
gravity since titan and space have
lighter gravity than earth but also
tony has become like incredibly frail
and it looks as though i'd hoped that
the visual effects team is the one who
digitally thinned him down
a lot and that created a really
interesting contrast beside
cap you gotta remember chris evans was
also digitally thinned down in the first
captain america so this is
visually right here linking tony stark
with the brave sacrificial hero steve
rogers
what he started as and kind of near the
end for tony but we're going to actually
get to more on stark and cap's opposite
end points later
inside avengers hq the screen shows
other mcu snap victims including oh my
god dr eric selva your favorite
the thor movies remember in the dark
world he had that loopy blackboard
it actually featured several theoretical
physics concepts that ended up being
true
in this movie things like shrew dinger's
cat referring to the quantum theory in
which
an unobservable thing exists in multiple
states until we look at it just like
the multiple realities that this movie's
version of time travel creates
or the way our brains were like oh okay
but also like
wait huh as we watch this stuff someday
i'm sure they will call it schrodinger's
loki
you'll see why stark reignites the
debate he had with cap and age of ultron
bringing back up this image of a suit of
armor around the world
and them losing but losing together that
scene in ultron was the origin of
endgame as the title of this movie we're
the avengers
we can bust arms dealers all the live
long day but that up there that's
that's the end game sounds like a good
title so rocket now is wearing this
slick blue suit which is a nod to the
blue button jumpsuit he wore in the 2008
guardian comics by dan avnet and also
andy lanning
he explains that thanos using the
infinity stones created it's my favorite
part of the movie actually it's real
subtle an
unprecedented energy surge we know that
the stones emit
gamma radiation right which gave bruce
banner his powers so
this wave of energy could have a side
effect that resulted in
boom mutants all over the universe being
introduced in the mcu
right now it's right here i said it was
my favorite part of the movie that's not
true i love this movie in a bunch of
different ways but
x-men could happen now it's possible
nebula explains that thanos's retirement
planet
is called the garden which is another
example of how the mad titan is being
depicted as a spiritual figure right
an infinity war thanos said that after
gathering the six stones he would
finally rest and watch the sun rise on a
grateful universe he's like the old
testament god in the book of genesis who
created slash destroyed everything in
six phases
and now resting on the seventh with this
garden kind of serving as the movie's
garden of eden paradise
so then thor greets captain marvel but
on the table before him are hawaiian
sweet rolls and
beer it's athena from the creature
comforts brewery and then later he
drinks tropical from creature comforts
so
right now we've already got this
indication of how thor has been carbon
loading into his depression leading to
the melted ice cream appearance he's got
going later also then they fly off on
the benatar through a hexagonal wormhole
in space that's the same kind we keep
seeing we saw it in the guardians movies
and in captain marvel that's how they
get to titan two and then there's this
close-up of capsule
i as the stars streak past it's actually
similar to the eye close-up that's in
the stargate sequence
in film nerds know this 2001 a space
odyssey but it's also in the opening
shot of blade runner cap looks at
a compass showing a photo of peggy
carter his longtime love from another
time
cap keeps her in this compass as a way
to symbolize the way that she was his
moral compass
and the way that she's kind of a north
star guiding his thematic journey
in this film when cap sat at her bedside
and went her soldiers she told him the
world has changed
none of us can go back all we can do is
our best
and sometimes the best that we can do is
to start over
it's interesting now to see how those
exact words inspired cap
and endgame to find a way to go back
before the world changed
and to start over then on titan 2 thanos
has now retired as
a just sweet old man farmer hanging his
armor up as a scarecrow just like how
thanos actually spends his post-snap
retirement
in the comics there's a shot of his
injured gauntlet grazing the weird corn
stalks that actually feels like a nod to
ridley scott's shot in gladiator the
warrior maximus is returning home he
keeps dreaming of that but then
ultimately when he finally gets that
it's because he's died so really it's
just like thanos's death here that we're
about to see because of course the
avengers crashed thanos's dinner which
is real rude and then they realized he
used the stones
to destroy the stones nebula says my
father's many things a liar is not one
of them and the movies actually keep
making that point
thanos never actually lies in infinity
war he told gamora
but i never taught you to lie and in
guardians vol 2
quill tells nebula you know you'd think
an evil super villain would learn how to
properly lie thanos never actually
needed to teach his daughters to lie
because also
it was a fail-safe against them ever
being able to betray him and his refusal
to lie
makes him way more fearsome since every
threat he makes
is a literal promise then thor goes for
the head
and killing off thanos early like this
is really a false victory now sure it's
exactly what we wanted thor to do and
sure there's a satisfaction to the thud
that brolin's head makes as it's brolin
on the floor but
kind of like seeing brad pitt given to
his wrath and execute the bald villain
of another spiritually based story
sev then number seven then like john doe
death is what thanos
wanted here and now the heroes are in an
even bleaker state the movie then jumps
five years into the future the
screenwriters marcus and mcfeely wanted
to evoke that
what reaction that viewers have to
surprising time jumps and tv shows like
in fargo and in lost this allows them to
actually start over and reimagine each
avenger and surprise us with how they
each respond to lost differently
post-apocalyptic new york is totally
covered in fog with boats moored at
liberty island and cap later says that
he spotted whales out in the hudson
river
since you know fewer boats have made the
water cleaner and marine life has been
less hunted but actually if you re-watch
that shot you can see
surfacing whales right there in the
water cap sits in a grief support group
featuring a big cameo by co-director joe
russo playing the first
openly gay character in the mcu
describing a depressing date that he
went on russo has played lots of
different characters in all of his
marvel movies the surgeon who faked nick
fury's death and winter soldier the
psychiatrist dr brassard in civil war
and bert the photographer in a deleted
scene from infinity war the group
actually is led by another cameo by
jim starlin author of the infinity
gauntlet series and co-creator the
thanos character
and we move on to san francisco where
scott lang's ex-con
van left stranded after ant-man and the
wasp is now in storage but the unit
number
is 616. a nod to marvel 616 the number
of the base reality in the marvel
multiverse from the comics actually we
saw spider-man into the spider-verse
amazing film the original peter parker
was from earth 616 and now the mcu is
establishing the existence
of multiple realities in this
live-action universe then the quantum
tunnel spits out scott and he alerts a
security guard played by ken jeong if
you weren't sure if it was him yeah it
was him the russo brothers worked with
jiang on the sitcom community and
there's actually another community cameo
with event nicole brown later in the
movie they've also cast community uh
actors danny poody and also jim rash in
past movies but here's the thing jeong's
character the security guard he's
reading a book by j.g
ballard called terminal breach it's a
1964 collection of short stories one
of which is titled endgame ballard is
known for his post-apocalyptic fiction
and considering the times it kind of
makes sense that people would be digging
this kind of literature
the black death of the middle ages which
wiped out half of europe
that actually similarly led to the
popularity of dark and really morbid
themes in literature and art
scott finds this memorial set up in the
park with names of victims that are
of course all easter eggs one is roberto
de costa aka the mutant sunspot from the
x-men comics really the first
firm acknowledgement of the x-men
characters in the mcu there are also
just like a ton of names of crew people
who worked on various marvel films and
tv shows but there's really too many
dimensions so let's just like snap
through them all
[Music]
that's good and then snapping back
oh what was it like down there
milk and back at adventures headquarters
natasha holds a conference call
while making a sandwich cutting it
diagonally which maybe is a nod to nick
fury who in captain marvel he revealed
he refuses to eat sandwiches diagonally
maybe natasha cuts her sandwiches that
way as a force of habit to keep fury's
flurking hands off her lunch
also during this call okoye mentions an
underwater earthquake which could be
establishing
the existence of namor and atlantis in
the mcu
they're at battle with wakanda in the
comics of various times so we could be
setting that up
right now also carol danvers just gotta
call out cute new haircut
not loving it but hey you do you it does
reflect the look that she has in the
comics and also when she turns to roadie
and she gives them that longer look than
normal saying be careful that actually
could be a nod to the romantic
relationship
between captain marvel and the actor don
cheadle in the comics
or wait no war machine and on the chair
beside natasha some ballet slippers are
visible this suggests that natasha's
probably returning to her ballet
training from her youth in the kgb
perhaps as a way to keep her focused and
centered maybe as a form of
self-discipline
scott lang shows up with the van
babbling about time and the quantum
realm and how the past five-year period
actually felt like only five hours to
him janet van dyne if you remember
hinted at the existence of time vortexes
in the quantum realm
in ant-man and the wasp and don't get
sucked into a time vortex we won't be
able to save you
this leads them to the new home of tony
stark everyone's on farms
stark's fulfilling his retirement dream
that he mentioned back at the end of age
of ultron maybe i should take a page out
of barton's book
build pepper a farm hope nobody blows it
up pepperidge farms oh my god
it's the whole time his daughter is
morgan the name he brought up to pepper
early in infinity war she wears a blue
iron man helmet which tony says he was
making for pepper
joking that she never wears anything he
buys for her he's foreshadowing the
later reveal of pepper's new rescue
armor
revealed in the final battle then tony
compares scott's time heist plan to the
plot of back to the future and when
scott says the rules are to never bet on
sporting events or meet your past self
those are obviously things that marty
mcfly does in back to the future part
two
the whole end game plot though is
actually structured pretty similarly
with the heroes sneaking around their
past selves
in the background of scenes from past
films falling in love with their mothers
it's real
amazing the screenwriters actually said
that they brought in professional
theoretical physicists they brought them
in to consult on this story and they
told them that real quantum physics do
not follow hollywood rules
one of those physicists might have been
david deutsch from oxford
whom stark name drops here quantum
fluctuation messes with the plank scale
which in turn triggers the deutsch
proposition davidoish is one of the
world's leading proponents of the many
worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics which proposes that alternate
histories and futures
exist which is really the basis of the
version of time travel in
avengers endgame deutsche moving on to
the reveal of bruce banner who has now
merged his brain
with the brawn of the hulk kind of like
eric he's adapted from the professor
hulk version of the character in the
comics the screenwriters said that while
working on civil war
they were inspired by the old marvel
what-if comics and dreamed of pursuing
wild hypotheticals for the avengers and
endgame
like what if the hulk is a smart
celebrity what if
thor is fat what if hawkeye becomes a
murderer
and also the broader what if of just
what if the avengers lost there's also a
few more cameos here the kids who asked
for autographs from hulk
are joe and anthony russo in disguise or
no it's actually their denis and nephews
the older one actually cameoed in winter
soldier too as the boy who recognized
cap in the museum stark looks at a photo
of himself and peter parker notice the
certificate from stark industries is
upside down because this is just a fake
photo to convince aunt may
that peter's internship was legit
there's also a nearby photo of howard
stark tony's father hinting at howard's
appearance later
stark cracks the code of time travel by
running a simulation on an inverted
mobius strip this movie's version of i
guess folding a napkin in half and
poking a pencil through it and stark
puts his daughter to bed
love you tons i love you three thousand
adorable because
morgan is referencing the fact that a
ton equals
two thousand pounds so she loves tony
three thousand
truly her father's daughter but he said
love you tons which would be four
thousand so
she's like she's a kid she's a child
dark also rejoins the team and says
scott's hilarious age fluctuation was
the result
of the epr paradox that's actually the
einstein podulsky rosen paradox it's
also connected to the idea of
schrodinger's cat basically that
subatomic particles
change when they're observed and
measured so scott meddling
in the quantum realm made it too chaotic
to control so stark's solution
are these quantum realm wristbands that
allow you to
move through time rather than time move
through you stark tells cap
i just want peace flashing him a peace
sign it's a nod to their past rivalry
and it's also not actually the opening
scene of iron man
yeah peace i love peace be out of a job
with peace stark seals the deal by
returning caps shield restored after its
damage in civil war but even more
interesting
stark also removes a reddish orangish
briefcase from his trunk
leak set photos revealed that this
briefcase was labeled barf
for stark's binary augmented retro
framing memory tech and civil war we
don't see stark explicitly barf in
endgame but he might have used it to
help the avengers scan their memories
about their encounters with infinity
stones in the past
or to help record his post-mortem
goodbye to pepper and morgan that
projected out of his helmet later so
moving on to the new asgard colony
located
in townsburg norway this is the same
location that odin actually fought the
frost giants in the first thor movie and
it's the location of the church
where the tesseract was hidden in
ragnarok odin sat on these norwegian
cliffs telling thor
remember this place in the comics says
guardians established a similar colony
on earth a floating city though of
asgard near broxton oklahoma
which is real creepy to citizens of
normal oklahoma
we get confirmation that the other
asgardians led by valkyrie were spared
by thanos in the beginning of infinity
war and then we meet my favorite
character in this movie
fat thor the best response to the
gratuitous shirtlessness that chris
hemsworth has brought into the mcu more
than anyone else he lives with
meek and korg from ragnarok core gets
voiced by ragnarok director taika watiti
and he wears the same pineapple shirt
that watiti wore
at comic con korg plays fortnite and
asks thor to scare away
a troll named noob noobmaster69 i am
going to fly to your house come down to
that basement where you're hiding in
and rip off your arms and shove them up
your butt maybe it's just me but
doesn't this kind of seem like a nod to
the furry flabby roommate ehrlich
bachman in silicon valley who defended
richard from the neighborhood bullies
you get in your [ __ ] house and you
get me five adderall or i'll split your
throat yeah that might be a reference
they're making in a disney movie
speaking of psychopath natasha finds
hawkeye in tokyo and as she flies in
half of the city's buildings have the
lights off reflecting half of its
residents being gone hawkeye has taken
on the ronin incarnation finally of this
character he's a lone japanese warrior
he kills the yakuza boss akihiko a
yakuza villain from the marvel comics he
and clint face off in a long
unbroken sword duel and the filmmakers
were able to pull this off because
akihiko is played by badass japanese
actor sanata hiroyuki
who has played a ton of yakuza and
samurai roles all over the place
including
shenzhen yoshida in the wolverine back
at hq banner scott and rody debate the
rules of time travel in this movie they
reference past time travel stories like
back to the future terminator time cop
handsome leap hot tub time machine but
the first reference
is star trek which actually was a direct
inspiration for the plot of endgame the
screenwriters said it was kevin feige
himself who tasked them to bring
time travel into the endgame story and
feige has compared the story to the
finale episode of star trek the next
generation which featured multiple
alternate timelines
all having to converge together to save
the universe rudy suggests killing
thanos as a baby a nod to the baby
hitler premise which we saw play out in
deadpool 2 but banner explains that time
travel in this movie does not
result in a ripple effect change to your
own timeline it creates a new branch
timeline alongside the original timeline
which remains unchanged so after a
successful test with clint
the gang comes back together stark calls
thor lebowski because
dude looks exactly like jeff bridges
playing the dude in the big lebowski
bridges also though
played obadiah stain in the first iron
man and thor being the dude now is also
kind of a call back to the guardians
marveling at his amazing physique in
infinity war
he is not a dude you're a dude
this is a man the adventures then
brainstormed their time heist leading
them to revisit the plot
of past marvel films so amazing
including thor the dark world which
thor drunkenly had been making fun of
the dark elves ooh
scary there's that photo of jane foster
and that's actually the same
image from the first avengers when
coulson explained why she
wasn't in that movie they realized that
three stones were in new york at the
same time the space stone and the
tesseract the mind stone and loki
scepter and the time stone
in the sanctum sanctorum in the aya
vagamoto necklace located over on
bleaker street actually originally the
screenwriter said that early drafts
featured tony stark going to asgard
instead considering the ether and the
tesseract were both briefly there at the
same time apparently
tony was going to be an invisible
stealth suit and then have to fight
heimdall who would be able to see him
there also rejected ideas to go to morag
when it was still underwater or to go to
the triskelion and they said that
someone was just going to hop in their
car and drive to dr strange's house yeah
eventually joe russo just said hey this
is
avengers end game why don't we just go
back to the first avengers and
everyone's like shut the front door and
real quick the side details of this
brainstorming session are amazing hulk
eats this ice cream flavor
a hunka hulka burning fudge remember
that was the ben jerry flavor a favorite
of wong in infinity war a hunger hulk
burning fudge is our favorite that's a
thing and uh yeah nebula just can't use
chopsticks apparently so
cab gives his pre-mission speech and
they throw their hands in and it creates
this really cool visual that they really
focus on from that above shot tony
stark's original arc reactor has that
same design that their fists are making
over the time travel devices platform
platform sure all of that is actually
foreshadowing that original arc
reactor's return
in the funeral scene it also foreshadows
the weakness that tony's old-school arc
reactor contains
which present-day tony actually is gonna
exploit also that hands-in shot is
similar to the cover of the issue of the
new avengers in which the marvel
illuminati used the infinity stone to
reassemble the infinity gauntlet so the
avengers then zip down into the quantum
realm flying through time vortexes or
textes they resemble wormhole tunnels
that each split off in different
directions reflecting the branch
timelines that these disruptions of the
main timeline will cause
okay let's break down each stone mission
one by one first let's talk about the
time stone which they retrieved by going
to the battle of new york from the first
avengers film in 2012
but banner hulk finds the ancient one
in the middle of this battle on the roof
of the sanctum santorum confirming that
sorcerers were actually helping in this
battle of new york just behind the
scenes kind of protecting
their own turf just the roof of their
building now you might be saying that
the ancient one was not
the guardian of the new york sanctum
before strange remember that was master
drum
but maybe drum was just on the ground
level here and the ancient one was
giving back up on the roof and yeah
everyone wants to see tilda swinton
again the ancient one knocks banner out
of his hulk body
into the astral plane just like she did
to steven strange when they first met in
commartosh and even though it's four
years before strange will even become a
sorcerer the ancient one is aware of him
and his destiny as sorcerer supreme
since remember she does have the time
stone she probably uses it to see into
the future so i guess if the ancient one
made anyone else aware of strange's
future
general importance that might explain
how hydra considered strange a person of
interest in 2014.
bruce banner stephen strange anyone
who's a threat so the ancient one draws
a big timeline and explains to banner
how removing the stones causes the
timeline to split
into branch realities her theory of
timeline meddling was actually
established already
by mordo back in doctor strange temporal
manipulations can create branches in
time
but banner then tells her that strange
willingly surrendered the time stone to
thanos and
a little light goes on above the ancient
one shining off her forehead we all got
excited because suddenly
all of our theories that doctor strange
had a mysterious plan involving
timelines were kind of confirmed except
they weren't exactly what we predicted
but they were very close the ancient one
said she was unable to see
past her death but she trusts that
future strange will know
more about the complexities of timelines
than anyone else could next
the reality stone in either form in
asgard back in 2013 during the events of
thor the dark world loki jane foster and
thor's mother friega
reappear from that movie freak asks thor
what's wrong with his eye and he says
that it was injured in the battle of
huracan
which is a callback to when he and sif
recalled the battle of hurricane in the
dark world i remember you celebrated the
battle of hurricane
so much that you nearly started the
second there's actually another really
cool mcu easter egg in asgard here but
first
thank you to honey for sponsoring this
breakdown honey is a free browser
extension to save you money when you
shop online
when you buy anything if you're not
actively shopping around for the best
deal then you're probably not
getting the best deal but honey actually
takes care of that for you so when you
shop online
honey scans the internet for coupon
codes and other discounts
then it automatically applies that
coupon with the biggest savings to your
card at checkout
is like magic it works on over 20 000
sites like amazon ebay gamestop best buy
and more
and it takes zero effort to install
really just two clicks by going to
joinhoney.com new rockstars
anyone can use honey because it works
for practically anything you buy online
in fact
10 million people are currently already
saving money with honey
10 million people that's insane just
look at these reviews actually from
other honey users
carity said if you order stuff regularly
without using honey you're actually
throwing money away and alicia said i'm
not one to use product services etc that
i see youtubers promote all that often
but after seeing someone talk about
honey i had to try it and let me tell
you
it's incredible now this might sound too
good to be true i get it it's like wait
this is free and it saves you money
what's going on but when you use a
coupon code provided by honey that's how
it works they earn a small commission
from the merchant and then they pass
along some of those savings to their
members
it's a win-win for everybody there's
really no reason not to start using
honey today it's free to use and
easiness on your computer in just two
clicks
get honey for free at joinhoney.com new
rockstar that's join honey.com
new rockstars and thanks again honey for
sponsoring this breakdown couldn't have
done it without you mwah
okay back to asgard when thor reconnects
with his mother
he drinks the same asgardian liquor that
he and calf shared with stan lee
in age of ultron this was aged for a
thousand years
the barrels built from the wreck of
grund hill's fleet is not
meant for mortal men neither was omaha
beach plunty
stop trying to scare us and after
rockets steals the ether
out of jane the asgardians chasing him
shout stop
rabbit apparently rocket just looks like
all the asgardian rabbits it just means
that asgardian rabbits are like pretty
jacked they're really big dudes
uh next the space stone and the mine
stone are in avengers tower and is back
in the battle of new york in 2012
one really cool thing about this
sequence is the way that it connects the
dots
between the end of the first avengers
movie and what it came after we've
always wondered some details here for
instance he previously had just shown up
randomly with like this mouth gag on
which could have been uh for a bunch of
weird reasons but actually was because
it was slapped on him by thor
after loki wouldn't stop impersonating
the other avengers like
cap setting up loki's later cap
impersonation in the dark world
then agent sitwell brock rumlow and
secretary pierce they all show up and
they're all secretly part of hydra
so when they take loki's scepter sitwell
mentions bringing
it to dr list which finally explains how
he came to have the scepter in the
beginning of age of ultron cap of course
then retrieves it in the callback to the
famous so good elevator scene from
winter soldier
but he avoids the fight completely by
just whispering hale hydra which
is actually a reference to the comics
where cap is actually potentially a
member of hydra and has a similar little
speech bubbles yeah that awkward time in
caps history we all just forget about
in the lobby thor says that they are
headed to lunch
a nod to the shawarma post-credits scene
after avengers
and tony has ant-man restaged the armor
infiltration from civil war
on his past self knowing that in 2012
that was before he got his arc reactor
surgery in iron man 3.
and that old school arc reactor would
make that version of stark vulnerable to
sudden cardiac arrest
as he was in the first iron man movie
but stark
is such an expert in the timeline of his
own armor generations
that he knew an electric shock from
thor's hammer wouldn't kill him
because remember in the first fight of
that movie with thor the lightning just
supercharged his suit
in every mcu film the new iron man armor
fixes vulnerabilities that were exposed
in previous films kind of like that
nanotech armor infinity war was just a
way to prevent ant-man from being able
to slip in the cracks as he didn't civil
war
but tony's knowledge here of his own
history allows him
to exploit a previous flaw in his own
system so then capp uses the same tactic
to defeat his past self
and score the mind stone the two caps
have the great fight with the younger
one saying i could do this all day which
the old man is rolling his eyes saying
uh i know but present cap breaks the
headlock by saying
bucky is alive which yeah that's the mcu
equivalent
of save martha
but actually it's not just that because
present cap is actually remembering
his fight with crossbones in civil war
when romelo distracts him and breaks his
concentration by bringing up bucky
now your buddy your bucky
what did you say martha stark almost got
away with the space stone
but his pastel forcing hulk to take the
stairs
caused hulk to smash through the door
and hit present stark later in the movie
stark says that the past has a way of
messing back with you
so present stark also walks away from
this medlin with a few bruises
thanks to his past self getting back at
him 2012 loki snatches the tesseract and
portals away
creating probably a new branch timeline
most likely but this forces start to
think back on the last time the space
stone
and extra pin particles were in the same
place and he realizes that
in 1970 his father howard stark worked
with hank pym
at the shield base at campbell lehigh in
new jersey that is the camp where steve
rogers trained in his first movie
and where cap realized hydra had
corrupted shield
and winter soldier that base got
destroyed then so stark and cab
jump again and here we see the final
stan lee cameo
he plays an anti-war hippie who drives
past a military base shouting make love
not war
but actually the bumper sticker on the
car also reads nuff said which was one
of stan's catchphrases
also cap's stolen uniform has the name
roscoe on it roscoe simons was the name
of the character who
briefly took over the captain america
mantle when steve rogers became nomad in
the comics meanwhile tony's stolen
blazer features the old school shield
logo from the comics this whole time
high seems to borrow a bit from the
christopher nolan movie inception
which is a similar group heist that
featured perfect timing
and layers within layers and here in
this deepest layer
while stealing the tesseract tony stark
has a cathartic reunion with his father
much like the father-son catharsis at
the bottom layer of inception howard
stark finds tony saying that he's
looking for dr zola
a reference to zola the hydra operative
who secretly corrupted shield
and cap finds peggy carter's office
reminding him of his wonderful north
star in this movie and then he goes into
hank pym's lab
where he passes the original ant-man
helmet from the comics
and he steals some pym particle vials
now we'll break down all the complicated
timeline ramifications
another timeline but we should note that
it's not really clear whether cap ever
returns
these hank pym particles so these
missing vials could be the source
of hank pym's distrust of howard stark
could you turn me into your errand boy
and now you try to steal my research
howard's driver is actually edwin jarvis
the origin of tony's jarvis voice and
the ai that would later become vision
he's played by james darcy who actually
plays jarvis in the agent carter tv
series
and this is actually the first character
to cross over
from marvel tv to the films sorry all
those promises to the netflix actors and
moving on to the power stone on morag
the planet in the beginning of the
guardians of the galaxy in 2014 natasha
kicks in orloni which is exactly what
peter quill did to that thing in the
opening credits of guardians
and we once again hear red bones come
and get your love from the volume one
mixtape but i love this so much and it's
also back to the future reference
uh just being able to see things from a
different perspective now and that
perspective has nebula and roadie
hearing quill
singing it out loud from a distance but
they can't hear the music it's in the
soundtrack so it makes them look like
even more of an idiot they were able to
grab the orb from the temple easily
enough
but nebula gets stuck behind because her
network gets crosswired
with past nebula who along with gamora
was still a child of thanos
here when the sisters realized that
thanos has found the first infinity
stone gamora expresses a hesitation
well it's the first of six her subtle
doubt here masks a hidden concern about
thanos overall plot
which will later justify pascamore's
sudden decision to switch sides
and while learning about nebula's
connection with the avengers past thanos
calls them unruly
which is a nod to the post-credits scene
that revealed the mcu thanos in which
the other described the avengers this
exact
and way cannot be ruled
and also i'm going to die suddenly when
ronan stabs my neck
and finally the soul stone on vormir
which nebula earlier described as
a dominion of death at the very center
of celestial existence
her use of the term celestial could be a
nod to marvel's celestials they're
ancient godlike beings whom we know from
the collector's story and guardians of
the galaxy and
they have a history with the infinity
stones red skull told thanos that the
soul stone has a special
wisdom unique to the other stones
perhaps the celestials establish the
soul stone on vormir with a stone keeper
and this blood sacrifice all to make it
extremely difficult for anyone to
gather all the stones as clint and
natasha head to vermeer clint says
we're kind of a long way from budapest
referencing the backstory between these
two
alluded to in the first avengers movie
you and i remember budapest very
differently in captain marvel nick fury
mentioned
only ever working in cities that begin
with the letter b leading some
speculation that the black widow solo
movie
could be a prequel with hawkeye and fury
finally showing us whatever they all
happen in budapest
and when these two meet red skull he
greets them as
natasha son of ivan clint son of edith
remember red skull greeted thanos as
lars being the name of his father the
fact that red skull greets clint as son
of edith barton his mother
could be a nod to the comics where clint
was abused by his father
and was really more connected to his mom
perhaps red skull as the keeper of the
soul stone has some insight to see which
parental figure really defined your soul
and identity natasha says she never even
knew her father named ivan so some are
saying her father could be ivan vanco
whiplash from iron man 2 but i don't
think so ivan is also one of the most
common russian names
also after a heartbreaking but kind of
badass struggle
natasha sacrifices herself so that
clint can get the stone restaging the
same pose and the exact same music
of gamora's death in infinity war
natasha dying here means that the gamora
of this timeline never needs to
it's a life for a life balance as all
things should be
that brings us to the end of the second
act and as we're looking ahead at this
third act we realize there is
so much more that we want to break down
so many easter eggs so many
connections to everything else and this
has been a long video it's a three hour
long movie we're breaking down
so we want to give this next act it's
due diligence and really the third act
of the movie is pretty much
its own movie all on its own so we're
going to break it down
in a separate breakdown it's going to
come out tomorrow if it's not up already
we're gonna explain the insane amounts
of easter eggs and marvel cameos how
this new thanos makes the thanos from
infinity war look like a saint
and how the hell cap left this timeline
or timelines
like i bet you're wondering did he have
to interact with red skull again to get
the salsa back can you put this also
back who knows we'll cover that all in
that next video but for the meantime
let us know which past timeline you wish
endgame spent more time exploring
comment down below with your thoughts
also keep an eye out for part two of
this breakdown
and subscribe to the new new rockstars
marvel podcast
it's called inside marvel this is gonna
be on there the next one's gonna be on
there
and mind blown the podcast will have
this content
sooner so if you can't wait go there get
it as soon as you can anywhere you get
your podcast itunes
spotify follow me on twitter at fimo and
on instagram phillip molina follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos
thank you guys so much for watching we
did it oh wait no we have a whole other
video
god no oh boy we'll go back to work
[Music]
you